when we first learn to multiply and
divide positive and negative numbers we
saw well look if you have a positive
number times a positive number I'm just
writing pause for short for positive
well that of course is going to be equal
to a positive number that you saw that
even before you learned about negative
numbers but it's also true if you had
the same sign a negative times a
negative that that was also going to be
equal to a positive number and the way
that you get a negative number is if you
multiplied or divided something of
different signs so if you have a
positive times the negative that would
give you a negative number or if you had
a negative negative times a positive
that also would give you a negative
number and here I wrote it for
multiplication but it also applies to
division a negative divided by a
negative is positive negative divided by
a positive would be negative now all of
these we thought about if we're only
multiplying or dividing two things but
I'll just think about what happens if we
multiply or divide three things or four
things or five things or or end things
together what we might expect so let's
say that we were to multiply a times and
now I'm going to write the dot four
times a times B times C a times B times
C now if I told you that these were all
positive numbers then you say okay a
times B times C is going to be positive
a times B would be positive and then
that times C is positive now what would
happen if I were to tell you that they
were all negative numbers what if a B
and C were all negative well if they
were all negative let me write it that
way let me actually write let's let me
write a B and C a B and C they're all
going to be negative so if that's the
case what is this product going to be
equal to well you're going to have a
negative here times a negative so a
negative times a negative a times B if
you do that first and we can when we
multiply these numbers that's going to
give you a positive so a times B is
going to give you a positive but then
you're going to multiply that times C
which is a negative so you're gonna have
a positive times a negative which is
going to be
a negative so this one if a times if a B
and C are all less than zero then the
product ABC is going to be is going to
be less than zero as well this whole
thing is going to be negative now if I
did something else if I said there's
other ways that I can make the product
negative if a is let's say that a
actually let me just write it this way
let's say that a is positive B is
negative B is negative and C is positive
and C is positive well here positive
times a negative if you do this first
positive times a negative is going to
give you a negative and then a negative
times a positive different signs is
going to give you a negative so this
whole thing this whole thing is going to
be a negative plus keep on doing we said
look if all of them were negative
then this thing would be negative that's
because I had three numbers you would
have had four numbers here what if I had
what if I had x what if I had times D
here and if I told you all of these
numbers were negative let's think about
if negative negative negative negative
and I can do the multiplication in any
order but I'll just go left to right
8 times B negative times a negative that
would yield a positive now if you
multiply that product times C positive
times a negative positive times a
negative positive times a negative that
would give you a negative and then you
multiply this negative times this
negative so this whole product ABC is
going to be negative but then we
multiply times the negative well
negative times a negative is going to be
a positive so this whole thing is going
to be a positive and so you're probably
seeing a pattern here if you're
multiplying a bunch of numbers if you're
multiplying a bunch of numbers and if
you have an odd number of negatives odd
number of negatives being multiplied
and/or divided I just did multiplication
here but this would have also been true
if these were all division symbols if
these were all division symbols we could
have we would have been able to say the
exact same thing
if you have an odd number of negative
numbers in your product or in your
quotient well then you're going to have
a negative you're going to have a
negative value for the entire expression
if you have an even if you have an even
number of negative well then the whole
thing is going to be the whole thing is
going to be positive and so you can view
these as generalizations of what we just
saw here positive times a positive you
have 0 negative 0 is actually an even
number so this would be positive
negative times a negative well that's an
even number of negatives you have two
negatives so that's this case again
that's this case again so you're going
to be positive either of these cases you
have one negative you have one negative
in either of these cases so that's going
to be this case odd number of negatives
so it's going to be a negative and so we
can use this knowledge to start dealing
with negative numbers and exponents so
if I were to say if I were to say I have
a to the let me throw a wild number here
a to the hundred and first power and we
know and we know that a is less than
zero what is this going to be well this
is taking 101 a's and multiplying them
together you have an odd number an odd
number of negatives being multiplied
together well this whole thing then is
going this whole thing is going to be
less than zero if we knew what a was we
could calculate some out but we know
that this thing is going to be negative
let's do something so and we could do it
other ways we could say something like
this if I actually let me try another
one what if I tell you that a is less
than zero and B is also less than zero
and if I had a to the 101 power divided
by B to the seventh power
what would this expression be would it
be positive or negative or zero maybe
well you see here a to the hundred first
power is you have a you have an odd
number of you have an odd number of
negative numbers being multiplied so
this whole thing is going to be make
this whole thing is going to be
negative and the same thing applies here
you have a negative number to an odd
power you have an odd number of this
negative number being multiplied
together so that's going to be negative
but then you have a negative divided by
a negative a negative divided by a
negative is going to be a positive so
this thing right here is going to be
positive so this is just a beginning and
in the next few videos watch we do a
bunch of examples that really test our
understanding of this